de l'anc souvenez vous à la fin du mois
de janvier dernier s'ouvrait le procès
de jardinier omar accusé d'avoir
assassiné sa patronne madame marchal ça
se passait dans le midi les preuves
concrètes était absente mais il fut
condamné à 18 ans de réclusion à la
sortie son avocat maître vergès comparé
à son client capitaine dreyfus condamné
injustement au début du siècle et pour
lui il y avait ils avaient eu affaire à
une justice raciste pour ses propos et
bien maître vergès s'est retrouvée mise
en examen pour avoir jeté le discrédit
sur la justice française et ce matin il
se trouvait à nice pour sa première
audition avec pas moins de trente deux
confrères venus le soutenir
reportage va les ermites didier beaumont
qu'est ce qui vous rend si joyeux ce qui
me rend je regrette c'est qu'on va
défendre la justice on va défendre la
crédibilité de la justice contre ceux
qui portent atteinte à cette crédibilité
radieux jacques vergès
ce qui ne devait être qu'une simple
audition par un juge d'instruction s'est
vite transformée en un véritable show
dans les rues de nice
32 des penseurs venus du monde entier
tous solidaires de l'avocat parisien et
de ses propos tenus après le verdict
condamnant omar raddad
des propos qui lui ont valu sa mise en
examen et qu'il est venu répéter plus
haut et plus fort devant le juge
d'instruction
je persiste je signe et je souligne deux
fois jeudi par exemple que quand j'ai
parlé de pommard avait été condamné
parce qu'ils étaient maghreb j'ai été
trop discret jeudi qu'il était condamnée
parce que le président du géant
conseiller à la cour d'appel d'aix est
président la cour d'assises des
alpes-maritimes a tenu a eu envers lui
une attitude raciste
ambiance potache et le coup troupe exide
32 avocat dans le bureau d'un juge
forcément ça coince un premier incident
prévisible
pouvoirs prévus seuls à les voir le
bâtonnier pour faire constater que nous
pouvons pas travailler dans d'autres
jeux sociaux
interlude histoire de trouver des locaux
plus spacieux
en attendant jacques vergès en a profité
pour faire quelques photos souvenir
d'une affaire qui risque de l'entraîner
devant le tribunal correctionnel ce qui
apparemment lui conviendrait tout à fait